[Music]
your Majesties your Royal Highnesses
laureates ladies and gentlemen they
install our our focus on tiara Nobel
Prize Targa and in facility it is a
great honor to introduce the Nobel
laureate in physics professor emeritus
Reiner vice
[Applause]
Your Majesty your Royal Highnesses
excellencies dear dear laureates and
ladies and gentlemen all three of us
bury Kip and I represent about 1,000
scientists engineers technicians
students and administrators who together
made Legos gravitational wave
discoveries being celebrated here
tonight we also celebrate
Ronald driver who died recently and
dedicated most of his professional life
to Lego he's represented here by his
brother Ian and his niece Ann we are
also enormous ly indebted to the
National Science Foundation of the
United States and the American public
for steady support over close to 50
years what was done is measured directly
with exquisitely sensitive instruments
gravitational waves predicted about a
hundred years ago by Albert Einstein
these waves are a new way to study the
universe and are expected to have a
significant impact on astronomy and
astrophysics in the years ahead the
waves travel with the velocity of light
and slightly squeezed and stretched
spaced transverse to the direction of
their motion the first waves we measured
came from the collisions of two black
holes each about thirty times the mass
of our Sun since then we've measured
four more events the most recent not
only with the LIGO instruments but also
with Virgo a French Italian detector
which has helped in localizing the
events on the sky all the black holes
events occurred at around a billion
years ago last August we measured the
waves from the collision of a pair of
neutron stars these are stars with the
mass of the Sun but about the size of
big city enormous ly dense objects
that event was seen by many other
astronomical instruments and
demonstrated the promise of multi
messenger astronomy and astrophysics
now for reasons probably related to the
popular vision of Albert Einstein and
also the threat posed by black holes and
comic books and science fiction our
gravitational wave discoveries have had
an amazing public impact shortly after
our initial announcements I saw this
advertisement in a New York City Subway
it's on the side of the car scientists
found gravitational waves in outer space
if only it were that easy to find an
apartment in New York City with a
walk-in closet okay that same week a
cartoon ran in The New Yorker magazine
showing two birds sitting on a tree
branch one looks to the other asking was
that you I heard just now or was it two
black holes colliding so we've made an
impact thank you
[Applause]